c'est à versailles que le président
emmanuel macron accueillait aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine une poignée de mains
appuyées chaleureux sur le tapis rouge
dans la cour de marbre du château les
deux chefs d'état salué par la garde
républicaine ont gagné un salon pour une
rencontre en petit comité puis un
déjeuner emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine sont ensuite allé inaugurer
l'exposition pierre legrand un tsar en
france consacrée au séjour du deçà en
france en 1717
l'exposition se tient au grand trianon
du 30 mai au 24 septembre 2010 est
l'occasion de découvrir plus de 150
oeuvres peintures sculptures arts
décoratifs tapisserie mais aussi livres
et manuscrits dont les deux tiers
appartiennent aux collections du
prestigieux musée de saint-pétersbourg
une exposition symbolique qui marque les
300 ans de relations diplomatiques entre
la france et la russie